[Applause]
i know that i've spent an incalculable
amount of hours trying to analyze all
the things i did wrong
but tonight for once i'm sure as hell we
did something right
drake brought his son adonis on stage
and that was just one of many exciting
moments from the 2021 billboard awards
and to you i want to dedicate this
towards you
host nick jonas kicked the night off by
showing us how
interactive the show would be in stark
contrast to many ward shows of the past
year
we have literally taken over l.a live
ditching his red suit the weeknd
officially said goodbye to the after
hours era
[Music]
i'd like to thank god that i don't have
to wear that red suit anymore thank you
pink celebrated her icon award with one
of her trademark aerial performances
but this time she was joined by her
nine-year-old daughter willow
singing with your little girl i mean i
know
she's so sweet she's so unaffected and
it's not even something she wants to do
i asked her i said do you want to take
singing lessons she's like no i'm
already good at it and i was like
but you can be better because everyone
can always be better she's like
another emotional moment of the night
rapper swizz beatz paying tribute to his
late friend dmx
he made music with royal passion he
spoke to the streets he spoke to the
world
i want everybody around the world to put
your x's up in the air
and make dmx rest in peace
and just days after its record-breaking
debut
bts performed their new song butter live
from korea
and to cap the night off nick hopped on
stage with joe and kevin for a jonas
brothers medley
accompanied by hit dj marshmallow
[Music]
another highlight of the ceremony megan
fox mouthing i love you while boyfriend
machine gun kelly accepted one of his
two awards that night
and the top rock artist is machine gun
kelly
on the red carpet meghan and mgk were
also seen packing on the pda
while nick was joined with white
priyanka tropra who stepped out in a
custom dolce in cabana gown
leading up to the billboard music awards
nick told et why he was excited to emcee
the big night
i'm excited you know i've been a fan of
this show for so long and and
obviously been a as a nominee a
presenter multiple times but to be asked
to host
just feels uh you know really special
and and one of my fellow
uh voice coaches kelly clarkson's been
killing it for a couple years on the
show
i was so to be the host on the year when
we're coming back into what feels like
life getting back to
a little version of normal is really
special and
and they've got a great set and kind of
take on how to give it some indoor
outdoor
feel with vaccinated fans and it's very
[Music]
exciting